you can't be scared of being something
being something in the beginning is
better than not being anything ever at
all
you know it's hard to get the match and
when you're just trading your time i
could literally stay in the holiday inn
but these [ __ ] faces don't listen
mindset that it is your fault
is the game and if you're capable you'll
be whatever the [ __ ] you want
[Music]
los angeles great day heading first to
go see uh
the ceo of activision uh kind of our
first meeting
i know a lot about him her reputation
bobby's got a great one and so
excited about that conversation later go
and see
uh media mogul manager extraordinaire
entrepreneur extraordinaire scooter
braun uh
and i'm looking forward to that i've
known scooter a long time this is dire
just been to and i love the whole braun
family his brother adam is the founder
of pencils of promise
a board that i'm extremely passionate
about uh
and then a couple other secret meetings
and uh
just a whole lot of phone calls and
vaynermedia stuff just
running the business on my cell phone
and some pods vlog's about to i thought
it was going to the office
i guess we're not we're going to home
looking forward to it should be a good
meeting we'll not be filming
uh what can i talk about let's uh well
i've got a few seconds here with you
guys i'm just going to look at some
tech headlines youtube says creators
will need 4
000. cryptocurrency massive decline
nothing interesting there what about
vine too you've been talking about that
divine two things
i think it's gonna have a pop from a lot
of the instagram snapchat personalities
for a second
and then if it's a good product it'll
get going you know it's hard to get the
match
so many of you struggle with the match
to get the match to start the fire is
very very difficult
um and uh and vine two will naturally
have that off the hype of what
it was and what it became and and don't
get twisted
vine is the absolute seed
that accelerated the influencer movement
in the youth culture along with you know
it was youtube
but youtube was not mobile centric right
it was desktop centric
babin and uh and it was vine
that was the precursor to what we saw on
snapchat
but more importantly long before
instagram
was reacting properly not copying
reacting enough with this copying [ __ ]
we copied snapchat they reacted uh long
before instagram reacted to snapchat's
phenomenon
it first reacted to vines phenomenon and
created one minute video instagram was
pictures
and uh and a lot of the vine celebrities
went to instagram where it was easier to
build even a bigger audience
and at scale and different demos not
just teenagers
and so uh vine has a very important kind
of like
quick history in uh in kind of the game
we're playing right now and so
vine two will be interesting to just see
what uh
what it does what the features are is it
good is it bad
you know my space rebooted it wasn't
good enough and that was it it had four
hundredths of a second i think vine has
eight hundredths of a second
i think that you'll see millions of
personalities people with instagram
followers snapchat followers and a lot
of my audience that has learned
you buy beats from property so i think a
lot of you will jump on vine to
day one and see if you can hit pay dirt
and virality
and and awareness and so we'll see
what's up
nice very good
[Music]
like basically the five days i take with
my wife every year
where i'm not allowed to have my cell
phone i have to put it in the safe
is when i get the most thinking as you
can imagine especially by like
six hours in i'm like i'm gonna kill
somebody and like
usually i'll just like sit on the beach
and like draw out like priorities
and uh creating top of the funnel
business for la is number one
i i'm really mindful of like getting my
energy into here like even
i'm accomplishing what i'm doing here
right now
guys please ping me if there's anything
going to answer for you all right have a
great day
[Music]
friday text them text them with me on it
tell them it's important to me
hi a couple of important meetings in la
that went well that's good heading for
scooter
heading to lunch with scooterburn yes
[Music]
you know it's worth our effort to
produce a great
super smart clever video where we got
out of pocket but we'd have to pay
for it you know james i'll give you an
example
[Music]
okay then i'll go i'll call in the
conference phil what i need from you is
to
project manage the the
open job descriptions of like
interviewing internally
and externally um what i think we need
to figure out
for my biggest thing that i'd like you
to figure out is like
how to get those candidates down to the
final two so that i can meet them
and have or final three and have that
conversation per job description
considering you're kind of negotiating
for like heavy discount or free
i think we should be able to fill all
those positions by the end of february
yeah
okay okay here we go all right thank you
guys
uh i'm heading out tomorrow morning
i've been following you so long thank
you man yeah it's like uh
i sent you actually a pair of the
sideways
for a service yeah i know exactly what
that is i saw it okay so yeah so
i sent it years ago when you're with the
jets
okay that's so awesome man so uh so with
my company yes
i built that brand up selling in 65
countries doing it all online
all because of crush it yep and i feel
like a [ __ ]
wow because i had to go back a year ago
and get a regular job
so yeah it's just one of those things so
that's why i'm down here in this monkey
suit
and it's like i don't think that's right
i think you're thinking about it wrong i
think you're thinking about it too short
term
like you could start up again in 24
months and of something else and
like do you know what i mean you know
what i've been doing i've been taking
care of
from all around the world i haven't told
them that i've gone back to take another
job
and i'm just and i feel like we're in a
time to where if i take care of the
presence online
so it still looks like a million dollar
brand online i think that should be okay
but it's
but yeah man i do it back in dude
you got it look you've gotta you gotta
sometimes take care of whatever the hell
you have to take care of
whether it's bills
honestly it's not about that i i think
here's how you think about it
if you think about your nine to six as
like you're just sleeping
it's basically what i'm doing like i'm
sleeping through this and then in the
evenings but i mean i'm getting phone
calls
today so the biggest struggle that i'm
having then within it is so and
it was phil knight the shoe dog
millionaire
or shoe dog yeah so he kept going back
to be an accountant and so i was like
you know what if i got to do that
to feed this machine but what i
underestimated was
a physical product growing a brand just
requires capital
beyond what what i was able to find on
my own and so i get that
so yeah so so i don't i i think of it as
a minor step back street
forward i'm running late for a meeting
thank you
thank you take care man thank you
brother
you know whether whether you fail
whether not achieving something is
is your fault or not having the mindset
that it is your fault
is the game you know just sitting and i
was writing this is for a lot of people
right now who have managers
you know and agents it's so easy to
blame your manager for not getting you
gigs
or making you pop except if you realize
you're the one who chose your manager
and you can fire them
it's so easy to say you're not winning
because your assistant sucks
until you realize you're the one who
empowers it
i could think my youtube thumbnails suck
but i also know that i'm the one who
empowers that decision and as you know
when we debated it
i was like okay i'll let you guys do it
and even though i think i'm right
like like it's just that like if you
always think that you're in charge
like if your husband's holding you back
divorce is ass
or choose you know i think we all make
choices
but my big thing is if you've made the
choice shut your [ __ ] mouth
like people that like well you've made
the choice but then you also want to
just complain about it all day is
[ __ ] loser [ __ ]
like you guys wouldn't care if i said
the thing for you to do is to go dance
outside if you go out
i have a funny feeling if i told the
three of you go outside right now and
dance for an
hour and your business will do 48
million dollars in revenue this year
you're gonna say yes i mean
business people care about their
business
and so what i'm telling you is that i'm
thrilled
to figure out what you guys care about
from your business standpoint
and deliver what i care about is putting
25 to 50 000
into the pocket of one or two or three
of my players
who know that they could never get that
dollar amount any other place
than vaynersports got it what's the
biggest impact
or best thing on your business
make sense bye-bye what's up brother
what's up brother good to see you
get this made it out you made it out
this is the crew we're doing some
filming
as well behind the scenes it's good to
see you brother youtube great to see you
lately
i know nick really well can you see him
where's drock he's not around huh no we
don't like him as much anymore
babin's just better looking yeah all
right you get cough or anything or water
no i think i'm pretty i'll take a water
actually still for you you want some
sparkling
no this is perfect harry vaynerchuk in
the house
hey brother good to see you man great to
see you always i think it's fun to be
back this is the third time you'll be on
the show
second time here first time i was in my
bedroom i remember because
i just remember it i don't know yeah so
i think i feel like i think the biggest
reason i'm willing to spit authentic
is because i don't think so highly of
myself meaning i'm not insecure
it's just that like me thinking nick is
not good
at something like business forget about
photography where who gives a [ __ ] like
me saying your business stinks even with
all my business
things i still think is just one [ __ ]
dude's opinion i understand it's
a solid opinion i understand that it
comes with some
heritage and value but it's still too
many great people who've won
so much in things have told me i'm not
gonna win and then i've won
that i know i'm the same and so i think
one of the reasons i'm willing to spit
is like
my opinion is still my opinion and like
you know
take it with a grain of salt i think
what takes everybody to the next level
is cutting out dumb [ __ ] i mean like
no question whether in your training in
your business
in your friendships do you understand
that if every person is listening right
now
started to weed off the friend that is
bringing the least value and i mean
they're a bad influence they're they're
they're bad mojo they're bad like bad i
mean they're just negative they're a
negative person so they're dragging you
down
they're selfish uh they have bad habits
like a drug
addiction or something and you don't
want to leave them i want to make sure
people people when they hear me say this
like oh you're [ __ ]
get rid of your friend no just if you
audit your circle of who you spend time
with if you just
spent less time with something that is
broken
and you added one person that was
incredibly
valuable your life would be a lot better
that's just real
such a pleasure man such a pleasure i do
hunker right there walter
walter such a pleasure let's go i heard
about like
some guy making a trade and his job was
on the line and so the kid didn't get to
play
so much but like like look at your
situation like what i'm so fascinated by
which is like
you're just about getting the at-bat
just about getting to be at bat or like
jake to home who got to play in a super
bowl as a quarterback
if the world league didn't exist for
that like six years
well then he would like he'd be you know
what about the receiver in that seahawks
patriots super bowl that had the
patriots not one
he would have been the mvp and he was
working at fedex like six weeks earlier
and then on the other side the corner
that made the interception that was uh
yeah it ended up being
like the same way same old thing man for
sure
such a pleasure man how are things
you ready for some savage [ __ ] i'm
always afraid of savage
about four years ago i was touring the
us i'm a tour bus for this hat company
did uh 41 states 175 different retailers
learned
all about retail et cetera distribution
all that
you know found an artist he wanted me to
rep him i'd never manage anybody
give him a piece of rob kardashian he
posted on instagram got 5 000
sold a piece a week later for a thousand
bucks now you're an artist
an artist artist artist artist not a rap
artist
now meghan trainor snoop dogg drake
jordan clarkson d'angelo russell huge 20
000 dollar paintings
five hundred thousand dollars probably
in top one all the emails ninety five
percent of the emails people come before
the art so i'm like wow
huge space in the price point art so i
was like i don't want to dilute the
brand but also i don't want to limit
our upset so i was like yo let's go 72
hours drop limited edition print
i made 17 grand three days i was like
wow huge [ __ ] space
for price point where do you get them
you get that [ __ ]
in ikea you don't really know i know the
whole space from an actual talent
standpoint he's the best in the world
he's not even [ __ ] close
from a steep speed standpoint i'm
talking 5x everybody else yeah like the
way we do [ __ ]
the way i do like like be good and make
a ton of it
and from a work ethic standpoint well
that's the only by the way
you don't have to say that part because
the other part doesn't work without it
yeah
you can't the reason speed doesn't
happen is
only two variables romance and work
ethic
well we have a problem i mean we have no
wife no kid our family
50 50 partners in what in iconic so this
is what we did so
[ __ ] around in 2016 i owned big
instagram accounts i started bartering
you have a million i have half a million
i'll post you twice you post me once
zero marketing
black friday of last year
but we keep watching your [ __ ] which we
started probably january last year and
you keep saying facebook facebook
facebook you know finally we're like yo
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] if he's so good and he's
saying keep saying it let's [ __ ] see
ready for this [ __ ] though february 27th
we go from squarespace shopify we invest
in facebook
one month one hold on i've been trying
to tell people like
it gets better it gets so much of course
it gets better when you make
month one she gets better it's getting
so good we're just starting
brother i mean i don't know how you know
you're busy
but like you know look it's like like
i don't know how to explain it more than
the way i'm explaining it like it's
much like i'm about to become one of the
100 most famous people in this country
on this same thesis same exactly it's
crazy no one's listening either we try
and tell people
i know no one listens that's by the way
do you know why i give away all my
advice for free
i realize nobody listens yeah so like
like
like i give away such good advice but
these [ __ ] faces don't listen
so that means i can still get mine and
then people like you were like i
do you know how much you guys love me i
love you
i think that we have a lot of cheat
codes that no one knows
because you're in the trenches yeah
because we're so [ __ ] the only people
that have cheat codes
are the people that actually are like
it's kind of like if we're using video
game terms
you can't know the cheat code unless
you're actually burning the bush
and realize the key was behind the
[ __ ] bush like i was great at zelda
because all i did was like i it was more
fun to me to find
which rock to push than beat the [ __ ]
game
i'm only about cheat codes like honestly
i will not make the most money
because i enjoy too much about the cheat
code yeah i just love [ __ ]
some people love to make money i don't
i like to break [ __ ] and the only way
you break [ __ ] is you're doing [ __ ] that
doesn't seem
to make any sense in the short term
until you're like why did this rock move
oh [ __ ]
coins you know we're waiting for my
buddy rohan oza to come in i think he
should be here any minute
uh there he is i see him walking in uh
came here for his 40th birthday years
ago
we've literally been missing two two
planes in the
in the night i haven't seen him in years
actually but communicate with him he's
crushing it
uh incredible brand guy vitamin water by
five just like
unlimited like a beast crushes it on a
shark tank and i'm just fond of him
looking forward to chopping it up with
him how long ago was that
46 well you haven't aged trying not to
man
you figured it out i remember i remember
the first lunch we had
me too at um down in the gramercy
we were both like all right we're gonna
do some things here
and we'll do some things together by the
way the good news is we have time but
it's really great to like
it just all you know it's funny i said
to somebody today i'm like
you already know who the 39 players are
going to be
20 years like it like it's actually so
it's not
probably the reason i've been having a
lot of energy to like keep reaching out
to you and make this happen i'm glad we
did it
is i was literally walking on the beach
and i'm like you know
i actually know already who's gonna win
and who do i like because there's people
gonna win but you don't be around
correct
correct correct and i'm like i have to
make a better commitment
because we're all the same character the
same people that are going to win are
the same character which is
which is literally we haven't seen each
other in like four years maybe
right and it feels like i saw yesterday
yeah and i feel like we've been talking
yes 100 so i i
said to myself you know what that's
exactly right i feel the same way about
them
as they do it's complete serendipity if
you're seeing somebody
but i'm going to do a little bit of a
better job
in trying to find more time with people
that i want to see that's it
simple as that go to the same i use the
word when i did my new year's post get
balanced
it doesn't mean we slow down it just
means
you maybe do less
of the smaller stuff and more
of the bigger stuff right that's right
it's just about no that's exactly right
because
like you can pack you i mean you do pack
your day but
you can just i pack my day but literally
31 kids are gonna leave comments on this
youtube vlog
about how cool they are that they're
pumped that i introduced they looked
into
like oh my god you're such a boss and
i'm gonna meet with six of them which is
amazing but
i got to learn from you and this stuff
but i might need to meet two of them
and be able to do like three like me
have this meeting
literally this meeting is happening
right now if it wasn't
i'd be meeting some influencer on
instagram
and some you know up-and-coming hip-hop
artists which is great
or a client or trying to buy uno from
mattel or whatever the [ __ ] i'm doing
but there's i'm trying to i've made a
mental list of like 30 40 guys and girls
and i'm like i'm gonna triple down on
those relationships
smart because they're valuable who does
one of them as well obviously of course
and that's a i've been saying [ __ ]
scooter's my homie homie homie
and i don't think i've seen him in 18
months because again i realize
ashton too i which i didn't pull off on
this trip because he had to fly to san
francisco
but like i already know who the [ __ ]
people are
i know who they are it's funny like like
ashton's it's unbelievable
because we've done stuff together yes
like people understand how smart that
guy
is i know well that's because he was a
real celebrity before he got smart
and brother the stuff he was a celebrity
on which was like
the 70s show even the ranch was doing
hey dude where's my car
like no the public perception was so
goofy but he's so smart and have
like the best i'm lost in tech
conversations with him the best
operating at a higher level the best the
best then you've got grocery where
grow some groceries try and match like
an hdb
and they work off of a low margin and
others realize they're working at a
higher margin
so they have higher pricing and they do
promos
that's right costco says you ship direct
to me yep it's a bulk item you're not
selling that's right
yep everyone's got their plane yes
it's like it's like the jungle right
lions can coexist even though they're
the strongest
lions can coexist with gazelle because
the gazelles are just i totally
understand
okay what happens today if you
introduced a t-rex
into the jungle well that's what's
happened so the t-rex
is eating everything the the greatest
part of that is
why the direct-to-consumer business is
going to be so important yeah but what
amazon is doing the problem is
if they had to operate their business on
a profitable basis like everybody else
it'd be a fair game that's fine but
they're making so much money in the left
hand
it doesn't matter what they're doing on
the right hand and then they're saying
well we're going to sell singles or
whatever it is but if your pricing at
costco is this my friend lost leaders
have existed for a long time they just
have the most macro [ __ ] lost leader
i don't know i don't know but he's like
legitimately do a place out here
no where do you stay sls really
yeah why where do you want me
i'm thinking about so nice to meet you
thank you for the hospitality
i'll talk to you soon brother
doesn't feel relaxing i mean i sleep i
like i can literally stay in the holiday
inn i like walk in go to sleep and leave
that's literally where i'm at thanks
brother i'll talk to you later
great to see you ron
how do you think uh like you guys were
talking about ashton
the beginning
it's like a whole different monster yeah
do you think uh
like it's just natural that you'll be
pigeonholed is like one thing like how
do you well at that scare
at that scale force the system with
other stuff that's one like
is like my personal demons i'm always
scared of
like being seen as one thing and not
being able to do the other stuff
interesting
if you are it you are it
if mark wahlberg is a movie star if
dwayne johnson is a movie star
then they go from being the rock and
from being marky mark
if i am a entrepreneurial mogul i won't
be the wine guy
that's all that people call me 2009 10
11 12
all i ever heard was oh the wine guy
you can't be scared of being something
being something in the beginning is
better than not being anything ever at
all
and if you're capable you'll be whatever
the [ __ ] you want
[Music]
you